[Music]
oh is this an exciting unboxing so
Marquez who I'm sure all of you know and
if you do not I will put a link in the
description he is an incredible Tech
content creator I am so hyped because he
just came out with his own line of shoes
and we have them here you may have seen
a bunch of other creators unbox them but
I'm so excited to check these out so
let's get into it the first thing is
like this bag I don't even know like
what type of is this like a is a shoe
carrying bag a thing like whatever this
is
I'm obsessed and I'm probably gonna put
a bunch of camera gear in it to be
honest with you so he's calling these
two five one because his first YouTube
video was two minutes and 51 seconds and
that was the beginning of his channel
the company that he partnered with is
called Adams I've never personally tried
their shoes before so I'm pretty excited
to check these out
oh gosh it has like a little strap too
like this is okay we'll get to the shoes
in a second but look at this
so nice oh we've got some documentation
I'll link in the description if you guys
want to check it out and get more info
let's check out the shoes gosh I love
this bag
oh
oh shoot look at these they're so light
wow wow look at these these feel awesome
I love like light shoes and these feel
so light I can't wait to get my little
foot in here so there's all sorts of
little details we've got the 251 here
NYC tag a little tag here on the tongue
which has the atoms Marquette signature
I love these laces they're like elastic
okay let's put our foot in here my foot
it's not your foot it's mine
[Music]
these laces are so great this is wow
they're so so soft why is no one told me
about Adam's shoes before
look at these oh my goodness is there
like a cool way to like tie them like
that I I'm so shook okay I'm gonna fall
over give you a little look
at the back of them so many nice details
Marquez these are sick freaking sick
this is not an embellishment I am
absolutely Shook at how comfortable
these shoes are especially like higher
top shoes I usually can't ever wear
these because this part's always like
super uncomfortable I love them I
absolutely love them
oh my gosh I don't even want to wear
them outside I don't want to get them
dirty these are so sick I'm just so glad
they fit because a lot of times with
shoes it's really hard to determine
Marquez did say in this video that these
do run a little bit big I'm actually
normally a seven and a half in pretty
much all of my shoes and these seem to
fit pretty much perfectly in Nikes I do
wear a size eight most of my Hoka shoes
are seven and a half so these fit me I
do have a little room in the tootsie
they feel actually like a perfect
freaking fit so I probably didn't need
to untie that really nice tie that they
did because I feel like I can just slip
these on off because those laces are
like elastic how do the cool people tie
their shoes like the shoe people again I
will put a link in the description and
huge thank you Marquez for sending me
these I absolutely love them and they're
so much you can get over how light they
are
they're so cool he did say that he spent
the last two years working on these
getting prototype after prototype and
being able to perfect them and I think
that you did just that because these are
freaking sick and I love them even
inside here like there's just little
details everywhere there's probably some
other secrets in here that we don't even
know about and they'll probably be
revealed in a later Marquez video thank
you guys for watching I'll put Link in
the description if you want to check
these out and with that I will see you
in the next video I'm gonna go take
these out for a little walk
foreign